depression is real
I mean dude Jesus Christ I know I like
am in like podcast mode right now but I
just this is a front man Jesus Christ
I'm trying here really I'm just trying
to get to some semblance of a [__]
normalcy I wake up and I the only thing
I do is is is play with my son
talk with my talk with Kristen and just
[__]
work out
in my garage like like I'm a [__]
a Jean-Claude Van Damme character in in
captivity
just with the tub
filling the tub up with the water and
putting a rope around it and just
lifting it up just like son of a [__]
this is what we got
do you remember that what is that movie
where he [__] filled up the tub he
was in captivity and they had a tub for
some reason in the jail
[Laughter]
this is the [__] Four Seasons
Penitentiary hit a tub and they gave him
rope who gives [__] people rope in
jail and he just tied it around his
self and then tied around the tub and
then filled up the tub and would like do
deadlifts with the tub
[__] movies you know bro they [__]
cut me out of [__] I did favors I did
favors for people
somebody was like hey will you be in my
movie I was like ah [__] all right
they cut me out of that [__] I did faith
I did favors for for friends I had
friends calling me just like hey man so
listen what you know that favor you did
for me yeah yeah we're just gonna We're
Not Gonna it's too much
dude like what is this world oh okay
cool you mean that day I [__] came
down to all the way to Malibu so I could
stand in a hot basement for eight hours
in a day and do one scene
now you're going to cut me out of that
okay cool
I think [__] Jesus goddamn they took
the worst part the worst of the worst
though is that they took my [__] they
took my Beat Bobby Flay episode off of
YouTube that was really detrimental to
my [__] mental
[Music]
congratulations